lorsque j'ai décidé de vous parler des
candidats j'ai dû me prendre en amont et
on s'est donc attaqué ensemble aux
candidats les plus médiatiques c'était
très difficile de faire autrement
aujourd'hui il ya d'autres candidats que
les principaux dont on a déjà parlé
ensemble ces candidats ils ont eu leurs
500 signatures et le 22 avril prochain
vous pourrez voter pour eux on va donc
voir très rapidement un tout petit
résumé de chacun d'eux et si vous sentez
que leurs idées vous intéresse vous
invite à aller voir leur programme qui
sera en description c'est le mieux que
je puisse faire avec les moyens que j'ai
et le temps qui m'est imparti
donc si vous voulez bien commencé
[Musique]
philippe poutou qu'elle est plutôt et le
candidat à la présidentielle du npa le
nouveau parti anticapitaliste pour la
seconde fois consécutive
il ya cinq ans il avait récolté inverse
que 15% des suffrages il est situé à
l'extrême gauche sur l'échiquier
politique
la fédé lutte sociale son cheval de
bataille et soin de faire la guerre au
patronat comme en témoigne son slogan de
campagne
nos vies pas leurs profits en frais
révolutionnaire et souhaite je cite en
finir avec le système capitaliste et
porte le projet d'une société
débarrassée de l'exploitation et de
toutes les oppressions
pour lui cela passe par des mesures
fortes comme un élargissement massif de
la sécurité sociale qui permettrait
d'avancer l'âge de la retraite à 60 ans
maximum après salaires aux étudiants ou
l'accessibilité et la gratuité à
l'avortement et à la contraception pour
ce qui est du temps de travail il le
réduit à 32 eur il montre le smic à 1700
euros et l'interdît les licenciements
niveau immigration il souhaite que
chaque personne qui arrive en france
puis s'y installer et jouir des mêmes
droits civiques que ses habitants
souhaitent aussi sortir du nucléaire et
tendre vers un modèle 100% énergies
renouvelables en ce qui concerne la
diplomatie contrairement à mélenchon et
ne remet pas en question la place de la
france dans l'union européenne
et enfin il souhaite mettre fin à l'état
d'urgence qui ne sert à rien selon lui
est désarmé dans une certaine mesure les
policiers nathalie arthaud
le second candidat dont je vous parlais
n'est pas un candidat mais une candidate
il s'agit de nathalie arthaud qui
représente le parti de la lutte ouvrière
elle aussi candidate pour la seconde
fois est d'ailleurs aussi
révolutionnaire niveau économie elle
veut interdire les licenciements et les
suppressions d'emplois en commençant par
les entreprises qui font des bénéfices
est lui aussi mettre fin à la propriété
privée des moyens de production des
usines des banques des transports et des
grandes chaînes de distribution
le but étant de nationaliser pour
éradiquer le chômage toujours sur
l'économie avait monté le smic vers 1800
euros nets et veut instaurer un minimum
retraite équivalant à ce smic niveau
social elle dépend de laïcité stricte
qui arrêterait toute forme de subvention
à l'enseignement religieux
elle se bat également pour les droits de
la femme qui passe pour elle par une
opposition au port du voile et à la
prostitution
enfin pour finir pour le social elle est
favorable à la régularisation des sans
papiers et un accueil des migrants
je cite à bras ouverts jean lassalle ou
un jeune avec un candidat que beaucoup
de médias qualifient d'ovni dans cette
campagne
mais ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on
l'appelle on l'appelle jean lassalle
l'ancien membre du modem fait campagne
de manière indépendante et combien
changer les choses en france
très attaché au monde rural ils
souhaitent faire de l'agriculture une
grande cause nationale passait sous
l'autorité du président la république
dans une optique similaire il souhaite
donner davantage de poids et
d'indépendance aux communes et mettre
fin à la financiarisation de l'écologie
en sortant progressivement du nucléaire
pour arriver sur des énergies 100%
renouvelable niveau économique il veut
lutter contre la spéculation financière
et mettre fin au chômage de masse en
remettant par exemple 25000 personnes au
travail dès l'été 2010 est dans des
postes non pourvus via pôle emploi
concernant l'éducation il veut favoriser
l'apprentissage en le rendant accessible
avant l'âge de 16 ans et créé des la
scolarité des parcours spécialisés pour
les artistes ou les sportifs dans ses
autres mesures on peut citer un service
civil ou militaire obligatoire
le maintien du mariage pour tous et la
renégociation des traités européens
nicolas dupont aignan nicolas dupont
aignan est le président du parti debout
la france parti qui se revendique
gaulliste et souverainistes il est
candidat c'est présidentielle et ce
n'est pas le point fois puisqu'il est
lui le score de 1 79 % en 2012
niveau économie nicolas dupont aignan
veut favoriser les entreprises
françaises le territoire français et
propose de réduire de moitié l'impôt sur
les bénéfices
lorsqu'ils sont réinvestis en france est
de créer un label tricolore pour tous
les produits fabriqués en france et qui
respecte des normes de qualité sociale
et environnementale et ce qu'ils nous
respectent pas ces normes hiltex leurs
importations
il veut aussi mettre en place un by
french acte qui réserverai trois quarts
des marchés publics aux entreprises qui
produisent en france au sujet de
l'europe
on reste dans une logique souverainiste
et c'est pourquoi il veut dénoncer les
traités européens les plus contraires à
l'indépendance de la france et les
renégocier d'immigration nicolas dupont
aignan veut sortir de l'espace schengen
renforcer les frontières et faire une
refonte du droit d'asile
il veut aussi ajouter 30 mille policiers
faire construire 40000 places de prison
et faire un établissement pénitentiaire
éloignés par des prisons sur des îles
francs
16 les signes kerguelen qui sont au sud
de l'océan indien
jacques cheminade le vétéran de cette
élection c'est jacques cheminade il a 75
ans et se présente pour la troisième
fois il espère faire mieux que ses
précédents scores de 25 % en 1995 il
aurait eu 23 % en 2007
le point phare du programme de cheminade
c'est la création d'un nouveau bretton
woods le principe c'est créer un ordre
monétaire international fondé sur le
développement mutuel lors cela passe par
l'annulation des dettes des états ou la
suppression des banques centrales aux
profils des banques au profit pardon des
banques nationales dans cette optique il
souhaite faire sortir la france de
l'union européenne et de la zone euro et
en plus de bâtir un nouvel ordre mondial
économique gymnastes souhaite se retirer
de l'otan et mettre fin à la
françafrique en créant un ministère du
co développement de la coopération et de
l'intégration niveau écologique qui ne
compte pas mettre fin à l'utilisation
nucléaire et sega l'un des points
emblématiques de son programme la
conquête spatiale
dans un premier temps ils souhaitent
investir massivement à des zones
industrielles scientifiques ainsi qu'un
village mais servirait selon lui qu'à se
rapprocher un peu plus de la conquête de
mars qui reste on véritable objectif
enfin qu'est son éducation il veut
augmenter le salaire des enseignants
doubler le financement alloué au
programme erasmus mettre en place un
système de soutien scolaire public et
gratuit ainsi que favoriser la création
de chorales je suis absolument désolé
d'avoir rigolé je prends ce mouvement
très au sérieux mais il est tard il est
beau c'est une ford est pas content il
est tard je suis fatigué on passe au
prochain candidat françois asselineau
on termine avec le fondateur de l'union
politique républicaine upr erika solino
qui se présente comme jean lassalle pour
la première fois sa première mesure sera
de sortir expressément de l'europe en
utilisant l'article 50 du traité sur
l'union européenne
le même que celui utilisé par les
britanniques pour le brésil cette sortie
de l'europe c'est le coeur de son projet
son parti du père a même été fondée dans
cet objectif
pour lui la constitution européenne est
la cause principale des problèmes de la
france
une fois sortie de l'europe il souhaite
mettre en place un nouveau frein et
sortir de l'otan car ce n'est pas un
grand fan des états unis non plus
plusieurs de ses sorties à ce sujet ont
d'ailleurs créé la polémique
je vous laisse regarder par vous même si
ça vous intéresse mais comme il
s'éloigne de l'europe et de l'otan et
souhaite se rapprocher de la chine et la
russie sur l'échiquier mondial
d'ailleurs à celui nos souhaite aussi
changer radicalement les
sion politique du pays en limitant à
deux les mandats consécutifs des élus en
revalorisant le vote blanc rendant
inéligible à vie les politiciens reconnu
coupable de corruption et en mettant en
place de nombreux référendum portant sur
la dette publique
l'immigration où la politique
énergétique par exemple côté économie à
celui novo nationalisée à 100%
edf gdf france télécom et tf1 abroger
les lois mâcon et la connerie verser des
allocations chômage au démissionnaire et
revaloriser le smic à 1300 euros nets et
l'investît aussi dans le secteur de la
défense qui est pour lui primordial
c'est pour ça qu'il envisage de doubler
son budget est de construire deux porte
avions
voilà c'est assez intense j'espère que
ça vous a donné les clés pour comprendre
un peu ce que souhaite faire ses
candidats et sur ce que sont leurs
projets si vous hésitez encore aller
voter j'ai fait une vidéo sur le vote
que je vous invite à voir
quant au vote en lui-même c'est un
moment important de la vie enfin de la
vie citoyenne et l'a vu tout court donc
déjà apprécié le mais surtout préparer
le et pour ça vous avez énormément de
ressources sur internet mais fait
toujours attention aux sources
renseignez-vous non seulement sur les
programmes mais sur la situation
actuelle du pays et si jamais si jamais
vous ne trouvez pas votre candidat idéal
vous pouvez toujours voter pour le moins
pire bon vote love peace